je souhaiterais profiter de cet article
1 qui entend promouvoir la sobriété du
numérique auprès de tous les publics
en premier lieu auprès de nos enfants
pour aborder un autre type d'empreintes
également préoccupante en particulier
dès le plus jeune âge
l'empreinte cognitive c'est l'un des
thèmes de la formation à l'utilisation
responsable des outils et à la
compréhension des contenus rudy
reichstett membre de l'observatoire des
radicalités politique et fondateur du
site conspiration h évoqué récemment la
rencontre entre une offre idéologie
complotistes mondialisé et des capacités
matérielles historique rendant possible
sac à sa propagation à travers donc ce
qu'on appellera très sains précisément
les écrans cette malle informations
cette surconsommation d'informations que
nous pourrions comparer à de la
malbouffe un coup cognitif sanitaires et
environnementales nos écrans sont les
armes du crime
idéal pour cambrioler notre attention
c'est ce que rappelait gérald bronner
sociologue hier sur france culture et
dans son dernier livre apocalypse
cognitive membres du conseil national de
l'éducation nationale il défend la piste
éducative et l'apprentissage de l'esprit
critique pour faire face à un marché
totalement dérégulé reprendre notre
souveraineté écologique et cognitive
passera donc par une éducation ciblées
et des mesures fortes préventive nous en
rediscuterons à l'article 16 dans le
cadre de l'obligation d'éco conception
des services numériques
le décret pris en conseil d'état devra
prendre en compte cet impératif de
protéger notre attention notamment dans
le cadre du référentiel général qui sera
mise en oeuvre
en conclusion et c'est le sens de mon
intervention je pense qu'une attention
préserver mieux armées et mieux prévenu
sera un levier indispensable à une
consommation plus responsable et moins
énergétivores merci chaque collègue
madame
filleul demande de parole sur l'article
merci de me donner la parole monsieur le
ministre messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le président une prise de
parole pour insister sur l'intérêt d'une
telle disposition à l'article 1er qui
peut paraître symbolique mais qui a en
réalité une grande importance si le
numérique a permis de maintenir
l'éducation et la formation de la
jeunesse pendant la crise sanitaire
l'explosion de son utilisation n'est pas
sans poser problème
c'est d'ailleurs l'objet de l'appel que
nous examinons aujourd'hui tablettes
ordinateurs smartphones serveurs sont
fabriqués à partir de métaux dont
l'extraction fait dans des pays peu
respectueux des normes environnementales
et sociales
un rythme qui mène à un épuisement de
ces ressources est extrêmement
polluantes par ailleurs l'énergie
nécessaire à leur chaîne de production
est majoritairement fossiles
le numérique c'est aussi une économie
c'est aussi pardon une consommation
électrique qui explose avec 6 à 10% de
la consommation électrique mondiale
enfin lorsqu'il ne fonctionne plus ou
sont devenus obsolètes les objets
numériques deviennent des déchets très
polluants et peu valorisé
tout cela s'apprend et il est impératif
que les jeunes aient conscience de
l'ensemble de ses impacts
environnementaux
c'est pourquoi l'école a un rôle majeur
à jouer pour sensibiliser éduquer à un
usage mesurées et responsables du
numérique et du quai est le meilleur
investissement que nous puissions faire
pour préserver notre planète
c'est pourquoi il faut intégrer dans la
formation des enseignants un
enseignement obligatoire à l'utilisation
responsable des outils numériques
je profite de cette prise de parole pour
saluer également le travail du sénat
celui de mon collègue jean-michel
houlgate mais également du président
chaise et le co-rapporteur monsieur
chevrollier qui démontre que notre
chambre est souvent à l'avant-garde des
problématiques sociétales importante
mais
merci madame fillol s'il n'y a plus de
demandes de parole nous passons à
l'examen de l'amendement 46 rectifier il
est présenté par monsieur gold
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre cher collègue
l'article premier permet de sensibiliser
les élèves des écoles des collèges et
des lycées à l'impact environnemental
des usages du numérique et à la sobriété
numérique alors qu environ 80 % de
l'empreinte environnementale et
numériques provient des terminaux la
limitation de leur renouvellement
constitue une question centrale pour
maîtriser cet impact
sans entrer dans les détails techniques
de leur fabrication il nous semble utile
que les élèves prennent conscience de
l'impact environnemental des biens
numériques qu'ils utilisent le présent
amendement supprime la mention relative
aux usages afin d'élargir la formation
prévue à cette thématique et inciter les
élèves à limiter le renouvellement de
leurs terminaux et adopter des
comportements responsables dans leurs
achats et des bonnes pratiques telles
que l'entretien et la réparation des
appareils ou encore le recours au
réemploi
je vous remercie si monsieur gold avis
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
oui madame la présidente la commission a
fait le choix de préciser que la
sensibilisation à l'école prévue par
l'article 1er doit porter sur l'impact
environnemental des usages du numérique
par une feinte de ne pas focaliser le
contenu pédagogique sur la seule
utilisation
c'est à dire ce que l'on fait avec
l'appareil lorsqu'il est allumé la
notion d' usage au contraire permet de
viser la façon suffisamment l'appareil
cette notion plus large englobant ainsi
la mise en veille de ses équipements la
nuit le choix d'un matériel réparable ou
reconditionnés
le fait de limiter le renouvellement
trop fréquent de ces équipements donc
l'objet de votre amendement semble donc
satisfait c'est donc une demande de
retraite ou à défaut un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre à vis du gouvernement
mais ma vie de madame la présidente
merci je mets donc au voile
146 rectifier avec deux avis
défavorables qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je
mets aux voix l'article 1er qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté article deux amendements 4
rectifié monsieur gold chers collègues
donc proposé par l'article de la
généralisation des modules relatifs à
l'éco conception de services numériques
au sein de la formation des ingénieurs
en informatique et pertinente
plus des trois quarts de l'empreinte
environnementale des numériques
provenant des terminaux il convient
d'insister sur la formation des
ingénieurs aussi en matière
d'écoconception des biens comportant des
éléments numériques tel est l'objet du
présent amendement
monsieur houlgate vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente donc
l'article 2 et vous l'avez vous l'avez
souligné un vise les formations
d'ingénieurs en informatique
et il poursuit donc l'objectif du
développement de ce que l'on pourrait
appeler une écologie du code
l'idée donc et que les futurs codeurs
nos futurs ingénieurs en informatique
puisse être formé la sobriété numérique
et plus particulièrement à
l'éco-conception et d'ailleurs je ferais
remarquer que cet article il est
complètement en cohérence avec ce qu'on
discutera de thaler l'article 16 qui
oblige à l'éco-conception pour pour les
foulées fournisseur de données les plus
importants mais qui aussi créer un
référentiel donc il faut que ce
référentiel qui est une volonté
politique puisse être appliquée par des
ingénieurs d'où le fait que cet article
donc concerne donc les ingénieurs en
informatique et cet article ne vise pas
les concepteurs et les fabricants de
terminaux numériques qui eux sont des
ingénieurs je dirais plutôt en
électronique
voilà donc avis défavorable merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre à vis du gouvernement
madame la présidente mon avis sera
défavorable une sur le présente
amendements mais je voulais juste
profiter de cet élément pour du coup
donné l'avis du gouvernement sur
l'article puisque nous avions eu
l'occasion d'en discuter en commission
et il est évident que la question de
l'éco-conception et des sites internet
de des outils de communications
électroniques est importante et que
c'est dans une forme prendre le sujet à
la racine que de le prendre par la
formation des ingénieurs toutefois et
j'avais eu l'occasion d'en parler enfin
d'en discuter lors de l'examen en
commission cet article est un des
articles sur lequel le gouvernement a
une réserve car il me semble que la
disposition est à la fois trop ciblées
pour être introduite dans la loi est
satisfaite par ailleurs assez largement
par une mesure qui vient d'être adopté
dans la loi de programmation pour la
recherche donc là et ppr promulgué le 24
décembre dernier je parle de l'article
41 2 7l ppr qui a permis d'inscrire dans
le code de l'éducation la
sensibilisation et la formation aux
enjeux de la transition écologique et du
développement durable il a été ainsi
inséré un 4 bis après l'article iv de
l'article l après le quatrième en pardon
du l'article l 123 2 du code de
l'éducation
pardon le service public de
l'enseignement supérieur contribuer à la
sensibilisation et à la formation aux
enjeux de la transition écologique et du
développement durable monsieur le
ministre je mets au voilà moment 4
rectifié qu'a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je mets
aux voix l'article 2 qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté l
article 5
un amendement 61 il est présenté
par monsieur chevènement rédactionnelle
amendements rédactionnels monsieur le
ministre à vis du gouvernement favorable
je mets donc on voit l'amendement 61 kg
a donc un avis favorable au gouvernement
qui pour qui et contre s'abstient il est
adopté
ces cinq rectifié monsieur gold merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues la numérisation durable
des petites et moyennes entreprises
constitue un défi de taille à l'heure de
la crise sanitaire qui implique leur
adaptation rapide
cette numérisation doit être la plus
vertueuse possible et la proposition de
loi permettra d encourager dans cette
direction l'article 5 instaure un crédit
d'impôt la numérisation durable des
petites et moyennes entreprises destiné
à prendre en charge 50 % des dépenses
d'accompagnement pour la mise en place
d'une stratégie de transformation
numérique de l'entreprise incluant la
sobriété numérique mais aussi les
dépenses d'acquisition d'équipements
numériques reconditionnés afin
d'encourager la gestion des ressources
informatiques et des matières premières
nécessaires à la fabrication des biens
le présente amendement propose de rendre
éligibles à ce crédit d'impôt les
dépenses destinées aux recours à des
équipements numériques issus de
l'économie de la fonctionnalité avis de
la commission monsieur houlgate
oui donc pour pour rappel donc vous
l'avez signalé donc l'article 5 créer un
et créer un crédit d'impôt à la
numérisation durable des petites et
moyennes entreprises qui permettent donc
de couvrir des dépenses qui sont liées à
la réalisation d'études d'impact
environnemental des services numériques
aux frais d'accompagnement pour la mise
en place d'une stratégie de
transformation numérique de l'entreprise
mais aussi pour les dépenses qu'ils sont
destinés à la cuisine et à l'acquisition
d'équipements numériques reconditionnés
donc cet amendement propose d'élargir
les dépenses éligibles à ce crédit
d'impôt aux dépenses qui sont destinés
aux recours à des équipements numériques
qui sont issus de l'économie de la
fonctionnalité alors l'économie de la
fonctionnalité peut se définir comme un
système économique privilégiant l'usagé
d'un produit plutôt que sa vente
le code de l'environnement mentionne à
ce jour la notion de pratiques
d'économie de la nationalité de
fonctionnalité pardon à l'article l 541
1 en tant que pratique vertueuse à
encourager permettant d'optimiser la
durée d'utilisation des matériels c'est
pas contestable au contraire néanmoins
la notion d' équipements issus de
l'économie de la fonctionnalité nous
paraît pas à ce stade précisément défini
à quai les équipements cela peut-il
renvoyé
qu'est-ce qui seraient couverts en plus
de l'article que l'article actuelle ne
permet pas de couvrir c'est apprendre
cet amendement poserait sans doute des
difficultés de mise en oeuvre et
d'identification de ces dépenses qui
sont éligibles au crédit d'impôt d'où un
avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre avait du gouvernement oui on a
le président tu voudrais propre et
profiter des commentaires de cet article
pour faire un petit correctif
donc j'étais favorable à l'amendement
rédactionnelles je voudrais rappeler que
comme je l'avais précisé en commission
nous sommes défavorables l'article dans
sa globalité
non pas que nous ne souhaitions pas
aider les tpe pme à être plus sobre dans
leurs dépenses
numérique ou en tout cas à évoluer vers
un numérique plus responsable de
l'environnement il ya d'ailleurs un
certain nombre d'appels à projets de
l'ademe afin de financer ce genre de
types d'investissements de la part des
tpe pme
mais en règle générale c'est vrai
d'ailleurs à titre personnel sur la
question de la numérisation des
entreprises qui pourtant un élément
extrêmement important pour mon ministère
je suis défavorable à aux crédits
d'impôt liés à la numérisation compte
tenu de la difficulté qu'il y à éviter
un certain nombre d'effets d'aubaine
massif et donc par extension je suis
défavorable au crédit d'impôt pour un
numérique environnementale ce qui ne
veut pas dire que nous ne soutenons pas
ce type d'investissement mais plutôt
bien de la subvention comprenons alors
je vais me trouver le 5 rectifié car ces
deux avis défavorables qui et pour qui
compte c'est bien il n'est pas adoptée
je me vois l'article 5 qui et pour qui
et contre qui s'abstient l'état adopté
article 6 une demande de parole de
monsieur françois bonhomme pour le
groupe l'est républicain
merci on a un président oui cet article
propose de réécrire le délit d' autres
faisant programmée afin d'améliorer
l'effectivité et je serai donc m'y
associer pleinement nous devons je crois
nous saisir de cet enjeu de
l'obsolescence programmée afin de rendre
cette proposition pleinement effective
et efficiente et de lui permettre de
garantir de ne pas en france de
numérique encore une fois sobre
responsable écologiquement vertueux la
limitation du rhône allemand des
terminaux dont la fabrication
je le rappelle est la distribution
représentent près de 70 % de l'empreinte
carbone numérique en france constitue en
effet un enjeu écologique majeure je
rappelle également que visé par une
enquête pour obsolescence programmée et
tromperie en 2018
le fabricant apple a en effet reconnu
qu'ils altéraient volontairement les
performances de ses iphone à batterie
vieillissante deux ans après le 16
février 2009 m
après si vous voyez ainsi condamné à
verser 25 millions d'euros dgccrf aux
pratiques commerciales trompeuses par
omission et pourtant
le fondement juridique retenue n'était
pas celui de l'obsolescence programmée
mais pratique commerciale trompeuse par
omission en l'espèce plus facile à
prouver
l'article 6 de la présente proposition
répond ainsi à une nécessité qui ne
saurait être ignorée il permet de rendre
opérant le diocèse sont programmés
aujourd'hui complètement inapplicable en
supprimant l'un des deux critères requis
pour le caractériser en effet à date
l'article l441 tiré 2 du code de la
consommation défini l'obsolescence
programmée par le recours à des
techniques parler pour lesquels par
lesquels le responsable de la mise sur
le marché d'un produit vise à réduire
délibérément la durée de vie pour en
augmenter le taux de remplacement
l'article 6 prévoit la suppression d'un
des deux critères d'intentionnalité
inscrira tic 440 1-2 celui de
l'intention délibérée d'augmenter le
taux de remplacement du terminal afin
que l'obsolescence programmée soit plus
simplement définit comme le recours à
des techniques par lesquels le
responsable de la mise sur le marché
d'un produit visant à réduire
délibérément la durée de vie par
conséquent force est de constater que le
standard de preuve actuellement requis
pour caractères et caractériser une
pratique d'obsolescence programmée ne se
révèlent souvent trop élevé et peut
prendre comme l'illustré le dossier
apple dans sa réponse au questionnaire
adressé par le rapporteur à déchets ccf
indique en effet que l'ensemble des
dossiers de la dgccrf instrus instruit
n'ont pu être menée à bien sur ce
fondement juridique faute de réunir les
éléments suffisants permettant de
caractériser le délit jours et donc
salué les travaux de la commission de
l'aménagement territoire développement
durable par cet article merci monsieur
bonhomme je mets ou voix l'article 6 qui
et pour qui compte c'est le sien il est
adopté
là je mets nouvel article cette même
vote
il est adopté article 8 amendements 49
rectifiée présentée par oui merci madame
la présidente l article 8 distingue les
mises à jour nécessaires à la conformité
du bien de celles qui ne le sont pas
afin de permettre à l'utilisateur
d'installer les seules mises à jour qui
n'entraveront pas le fonctionnement de
son bien
le rendant prématurément obsolète si la
conformité d'un bien est défini à
l'article l 217 5 du code de la
consommation
il convient de lever toute ambiguïté et
de sécuriser l'application de cet
article
cet amendement précise donc que les
mises à jour nécessaires à la conformité
du bien sont les mises à jour corrective
et de sécurité à l'exclusion des mises à
jour évolutive
cette distinction étant retenu par la
résolution du parlement européen vers un
marché unique plus durable pour les
entreprises et les consommateurs du 25
novembre 2010 je vous remercie
merci madame carrère alors c'est
monsieur chevrollier pour la commission
oui merci madame la présidente
la terminologie de mises à jour
nécessaires la conformité du bien
découlent directement les directives
européennes 2019 que l'article 8 en
question contribuer à transposer les
mises à jour nécessaires à la conformité
du bien correspondant pratique aux mises
à jour corrective et aux mises à jour de
sécurité comme le rappelle cet
amendement toutefois une telle précision
ne semble pas nécessaires à la bonne
compréhension du droit et serait donc
superfétatoire c'est donc une demande de
retrait sinon un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur et ses
ministres
oui madame la présidente je serais
défavorable à cet amendement je profite
de cette prise de parole pour signaler
que delà du point de vue du gouvernement
les articles 8 et 9 sont déjà satisfaits
notamment dans le cadre de la
transposition des directives 2010 9 770
ces 2010 9 771 qui est en cours et par
lesquels pour lesquelles le gouvernement
a été habilité
dans le projet de loi du même si sur
l'article aux 8es sur l'article 9 nous
partageons la proche proposé par le
texte
merci monsieur le ministre je mets au
voile amendement 49 rectifié qu'a reçu
deux avis défavorables qui et pour qui
et contre qui savent sert il n'est pas
adopté je mets le voile article wiki
pour qui et contre s'abstient il est
adopté je me vois l'article 9 même vote
il est adopté je me vois l'article 10
même vote
il est adopté je me vois l'article 11
il est adopté après l'article dans un
amendement 57 rectifie les présentée par
monsieur morin remercié la présidente
celui-ci mes chers collègues nous avons
eu l'occasion à plusieurs reprises de
rappeler que 80 % de l'empreinte carbone
du numérique provient du renouvellement
des terminaux et donc il convient de
limiter ce renouvellement et à ce titre
de favoriser le développement du marché
des reconditionnés qui aujourd'hui
représenterait déjà à peu près 10%
la présente proposition de loi prévoit
de diminuer le taux de tva appliqué à
ces produits et c'est une très bonne
chose mais au moins on observe un
certain nombre de réticences encore de
la part des consommateurs et des
utilisateurs vis-à-vis des produits
reconditionnés et donc afin de rassurer
seul le public par rapport à la qualité
de ses produits
nous proposons que l'article l 122 21
qui prévoit de l'élaboration d'un décret
nous vous proposons que ce décret
précise les règles en matière de qualité
de traçabilité des produits en précisant
notamment l'affichage des pays de
provenance et de reconditionnement si
chers collègues avis de la commission
monsieur houlgate
merci madame la présidente donc la loi
hajek a donc prévu qu'un décret précise
les conditions dans lesquelles un
produit peut recevoir la qualification
de produits reconditionnés instaurant
ainsi de fait une forme de labellisation
du reconditionnement
nous partageons totalement
objet de cet amendement et si nous
voulons en effet développer cette
filière est essentielle il faut lever un
certain nombre de freins au premier rang
desquels la confiance en la fiabilité et
en la qualité du produit et
reconditionnés c'est pourquoi il
convient de prévoir donc des garanties
de traçabilité de ses produits afin que
le consommateur puisse avoir la garantie
qu'un certain nombre de prescriptions
liées à la qualité du produit ont été
respectées ainsi que des informations
sur la provenance et le lieu du
reconditionnement de cette prose de ses
produits c'est donc un avis favorable
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
à vis du gouvernement
une à la présente le présente amendement
propose de compléter donc l'article l
122 21 du code de la consommation qui
prévoit que les conditions d'utilisation
de la mention reconditionnés ou produire
contient ils sont précisées par décret
deux présentes avant de m'en apporter de
nouvelles exigences pour les produits
électriques et électroniques pour
l'utilisation de ces mentions en matière
de conformité de contrôle du
fonctionnement de suppression des
données d'affichage des pays de
provenance et de reconditionnement du
produit or l'article en question
concerne tous les produits contiennent
reconditionnés et pas seulement ces deux
catégories d'équipements ces éléments
font d'ores et déjà l'objet d'un projet
de décret en cours d'élaboration par le
gouvernement il nous semble donc pas
nécessaire de modifier la loi par
conséquent nous serons défavorable à cet
amendement
monsieur le ministre je mets au voile
amendement 57 rectifie qui a reçu un
avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui pour qui
et contre qui s'abstient l'amendement 57
rectifier et adopté après l'article dans
un amendement 19 présenté par m à
l'ariana
nous reprenons ici des débats qui nous
ont que nous avons eue lors de la loi
sur l'économie circulaire mais qui ont
toute leur place dans cette proposition
de loi sur l'impact du numérique sur
l'environnement
notre société fondée sur un modèle
économique qui valorise la production
maximale de biens vise à une hyper
consommation permettant des bénéfices
pour les producteurs et donc une
production de déchets très importante
pour lutter contre ce paradigme de
nombreux
de nombreuses mesures ont été prises
dans la loi sur l'économie circulaire
alors que la présente loi revient sur
les dispositifs permettant d'augmenter
la durée de vie des équipements et
appareils numériques notamment par une
extension de la durée de la garantie
légale de conformité par le présent
article
il semble opportun d'aller plus loin en
ce sens nous proposons ainsi par cet
amendement de renforcer cet aspect en
faisant de la garantie légale de
conformité un outil au service de
l'allongement de la durée de vie des
produits
la garantie légale et le premier levier
à la disposition du consommateur pour se
protéger des pannes et de l'obsolescence
accélérée pour que cet outil contribuer
à la transition vers une économie
circulaire il doit favoriser la
réparation ou remplacement des biens 1
600 amendements proposent plusieurs
dispositions pour améliorer le mécanisme
de la garantie avec plus de transparence
soit la proportion des biens remplacé
dans le cadre du rapport rse et en
imposant la remise d'un rapport détaillé
sur les actes de réparation effectués
merci chers collègues avis de la
commission monsieur chevrollier oui
merci mme la présidente cet amendement
vise par des moyens très hétérogène à ce
que la réparation soit privilégie par
rapport aux remplacements dans le cadre
de la garantie légale de conformité sur
un premier point la partie de l'âme en
demandant à ce que la réparation soient
rendus prioritaire par rapport aux
remplacements et c'est en partie
satisfaits par les modifications
introduites par la loi à gec la loi geiq
prévoit en effet qu'à compter de 2022
dès lors que le consommateur fera le
choix de la réparation mais que celle ci
ne sera pas mise en oeuvre par le
vendeur le consommateur pourra demander
le remplacement du bien qui
s'accompagnera dans ce cas d'un
renouvellement intégral de la garantie
légale de conformité
il ya donc une incitation forte pour le
vendeur a privilégié la réparation
deuxième point l'obligation de
justification par écrit aux clients du
fait que la réparation entraînerait un
coût disproportionné introduira une
contrainte pour le vendeur sans pour
autant que le droit du consommateur soit
réellement accrue troisièmement enfin
l'obligation de remise d'un rapport au
client avec le détail des réparations
effectuées la nature des pièces
détachées installé ne nous sommes pas
relever du cadre juridique relatif à la
garantie légale de conformité
il en va de même pour l'inscription de
la proportion de produire
en place et réparer ou remboursé dans le
cadre du rapport rse des entreprises
nous émettons donc un avis défavorable
si monsieur le rapporteur mais seul
ministre à vis du gouvernement
identique donc je ne vois l'amendement
19 cas reçu deux avis défavorables qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté toujours après
l'article le onze nous avons un
amendement 22 et c'est madame à madame
grès hommes qu'ils présentent
merci madame la présidente j'ai bien
entendu concernant l'extension de
garantie notamment sur les réparations
cet amendement propose ne m'a pas cet
amendement nous avions déjà soumis lors
de l'examen de loi sur l'économie
circulaire la mise en oeuvre d'une
garantie générale de bon fonctionnement
de six mois sur les biens réparer en
dehors de la de la garantie légale donc
ca plus il s'agit ainsi d' aller au-delà
de ce qui est actuellement prévu par la
loi c'est à dire en cas de réparation
dans le cas de la garantie de conformité
en une extension de celle ci de six mois
et la réinitialisation de la garantie en
cas de remplacement
nous estimons que le législateur peut
aller encore plus loin en effet dans 60%
des cas de panne le consommateur
n'essaye pas de faire réparer son
produit pourtant dans une économie
circulaire la réparation et
reconditionnement doivent être
encouragés car ces solutions permettent
d'allonger la durée de vie des produits
et sont vertueuses sont le plan
environnemental
actuellement une fois la garantie d'un
bien dépasser du sachet peut faire le
choix de ce retour de se tourner vers un
réparateur professionnels
toutefois à la suite d'une réparation
une défaillance peut survenir sans
aucune protection juridique pour le
client ce qui peut le dise wade d'avoir
recours à cette solution
nombre de réparateurs indépendants
offrent des jeunes garantie de trois
mois à leurs clients avant de
généraliser cette pratique de protéger
les consommateurs et de les inciter à
réparer leurs produits plutôt qu'en en
racheter un neuf
une garantie légale sur les actes de
réparation professionnel doit pouvoir
est offert pendant au moins
moi partout les réparateurs merci merci
madame grès homme monsieur houlgate pour
la vie de la commission à s'y méprendre
mais cet amendement nous semble déjà
satisfait en effet l'article 22 de la
loi geiq prévoit déjà qu'à compter du
1er janvier 2022 tout produit qui sera
réparé dans le cadre de la garantie
légale de conformité bénéficiera d'une
extension de cette garantie de 6 mois
donc c'est une demande de retrait sinon
un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur mais ce
mini ce même avis mais ma vie je mets au
voile amendes et les retirer il est
retiré
alors après l'article en un amendement
21 et c'est madame varaillas script
présente par cette amende devant nous
souhaitons renforcer les dispositifs
prévus sur lundi serait pas réparabilité
nous proposons ainsi d'aller au delà en
permettant une information systématique
du consommateur sur la durée de vie
programmée du produit il s'agit de deux
informations complémentaires nécessaires
à la bonne information du consommateur
lui permettant de faire des choix
éclairés de favoriser l'achat de biens
durables est réparable et chers
collègues avis de la commission monsieur
chevrollier oui mais là la présidente la
formation sur la durée de vie programmée
du produit viendrait s'ajouter à les
indices de durabilité devant entrer en
vigueur en 2024
par souci de clarté ne nous semble pas
pertinent de multiplier les sources
d'information pour le consommateur par
ailleurs je note que la rédaction cet
amendement conduirait à imposer cette
obligation à l'ensemble des équipements
électriques et électroniques et pas
seulement aux équipements numériques
seuls concernés par cette proposition de
loi c'est donc une demande de retrait
sinon un avis défavorable
si monsieur le rat par trois sa mini ce
même avis je le moment est bien
maintenue je le mets donc aux voix
avec deux avis défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adoptée toujours après l'article 11
un amendement 18
c'est monsieur là et là qu'il présente
oui merci madame la présidente de par
cet amendement nous souhaitons que
soient mises en oeuvre
un réel compteur d'usagé sur certains
produits notamment sur les équipements
électroniques et numériques
aujourd'hui les compteurs des usages ne
sont pas obligatoires et nous
considérons que ce serait un plus une
garantie que de pouvoir compter sur ces
compteurs d'usagé
en tout cas les dispositions actuelles
nous semble en tout cas très
insuffisante
nous compensons donc le compteur relève
de la nécessaire transparence de
l'information sur la durée de vie des
produits participant ainsi à la lutte
aussi contre l'obsolescence programmée
c'est ainsi donc que nous proposons cet
amendement merci de votre attention
merci à vis de la commission monsieur le
gat
oui alors la mise en place cet
amendement selon me poser plusieurs
difficultés d'abord premièrement la mise
en place d'un conteur d'uzège pourrait
s'avérer particulièrement complexe un
dispositif aussi lourd s'il devait être
mise en place devrait être
impérativement être harmonisées au
niveau du marché unique
nous sommes donc pas favorable à un
dispositif national notons cependant que
dans une résolution du 25 novembre 2020
le parlement européen s'est prononcé en
faveur de la mise en place de compteurs
des usages au niveau européen donc il
pourrait donc être intéressant de porter
ce sujet à cette échelle donc c'est un
amendement d'appel
et puis par ailleurs la rédaction d'un
amendement tel qu'il est fait à l'heure
actuelle conduirait introduit un conteur
d'usagé sur les équipements numériques
mais aussi sur les appareils
électroménagers qui ne sont pas visés
par la proposition de loi enfin je
dirais en complément que il y a aussi
des compteurs n'ont peut-être pas des
compteurs d'usagé des compteurs de temps
passé sur les écrans qui sont qui
commencent à être mises en oeuvre alors
cette fois-ci de façon volontaire par
les par certains opérateurs au passage
certains fabricants d'équipements mais
donc c'est pour nous un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre à vivonne à ma précédente avis
défavorable jeu mais envoie l'amendement
18 qui a reçu deux avis défavorables qui
et pour qui et contre qui savent cyril
n'est pas adopté l article 12 un
amendement 60
il est présenté par monsieur houlgate
certains amendements rédactionnels
merci monsieur le ministre vis du
gouvernement
oui mais même là la présidente il ne
s'agit évidemment pas d'être défavorable
à l'amendement tant que tel mais il nous
semble que cet article déjà
satisfait car déjà prévu dans la loi
hajek
car la proposition vise la fixation
d'objectifs spécifiques de recyclage de
réemploi et de réparation pour certaines
catégories d'équipements numériques
elle est articulée avec les avancées
opérer je lisais par la loi à jacques
relatives aux fonds de réemploi et de
réutilisation ainsi qu'au fond
réparation et je tiens à annoncer devant
la haute assemblée que ces mesures
seront intégrés dans les cahiers des
charges des éco organismes des heureux
en 2021 il nous semble d'ailleurs
essentiel de laisser le temps aux
dispositifs de se mettre en place et
d'analyser leur efficacité avant de
modifier ces règles c'est pour quoi tous
seront défavorables à l'article et
partant à cet amendement rédactionnelles
merci monsieur le ministre je mets donc
voilà moment 60 de la commission qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté je je présente jeux wii nous
présentons maintenant l'amendement 11 et
c'est madame grès homme qu'il faisant
cet article prévoyait initialement des
objectifs spécifiques de recyclage d'eau
réemploi et de réparation pour certaines
catégories d'équipements numériques fixé
par les cahiers des charges des éco
organismes de la filière des déchets
d'équipements électriques et
électroniques
l'entrée en vigueur de tels objectifs a
été décalé par la commission en 2028
soit dans sept ans pour justifier de ce
report cet amendement s'appuie sur des
évolutions législatives nombreuses
apportées par la loi relative à
l'économie circulaire certes de
nouvelles obligations sont imposés on
peut citer notamment la création d'un
faux de réemploi ainsi que des objectifs
plus ambitieux de réemploi dans le
cahier des charges des éco-organismes
dans une logique d'obligations non plus
de moyens mais bien de résultats ces
évolutions sont positives pour autant il
y alors que cet article a pas simplement
une déclinaison spécifique pour les
terminaux numériques dont le niveau de
co
et eto'o de recyclage des impôts et de
réparation sont aujourd'hui insuffisant
nous ne voyons pas bien pourquoi un tel
temps d'adaptation est octroyé un nouvel
agrément tenant compte des évolutions
législatives et réglementaires liées à
la loi relative à la lutte contre le
gaspillage et à l'économie circulaire
est prévue pour le 1er janvier 2022
alors que la commission a reconnu le
caractère complémentaire des différentes
obligations posées à la fois par la loi
l'aic et par cette proposition de loi
il semble que l'entrée en vigueur de ce
dispositif peut être portée à 2022 afin
d'intégrer le nouvel agrément des éco
organismes reporté de six ans
l'obligation définie serait un très
mauvais signal envoyé en faveur dans la
lutte contre les déchets liés aux
équipements électroniques et numériques
nous proposons donc une autre est en
vigueur au 1er janvier 2022 merci merci
cher collègue monsieur chevrollier avis
la commission
oui mais la présidente l'article 12
prévoit dans le prolongement de ce qui a
été fait dans la loi j'ai que les
cahiers des charges des éco organismes
de la filière d3e fixe des objectifs
spécifiques de recyclage de réemploi et
de réparation pour certaines catégories
d'équipements numériques
l'idée de cibler les smartphones et
tablettes afin d'éviter qu'ils soient
noyés dans les objectifs communs pour
toute la filière
l'idée est bien ce faisant de pousser à
l'amélioration de la collecte de ces
produits aujourd'hui concrètement limité
la commission a souhaité à l'initiative
de notre collègue martha de cidre
hackett qui était rapporteur de la loi à
jacques pouvoir laisser le temps aux
acteurs de la filière de s'organiser en
effet une telle modification est loin
d'être anodine et nécessiterait de
mettre en oeuvre de nouveaux flux
distincts ce qui est relativement lourd
à organiser le nouvel agrément en
prenant en compte toutes les
modifications de la loi gect doit être
adopté début 2022
il serait particulièrement difficile
d'imposer aux acteurs d'ajouter une
nouvelle disposition
on ne sait pas quand le texte sera
définitivement adoptée seulement
quelques mois ou quelques semaines avant
le nouvel agrément
on sait en effet que le processus de
renégociation de du nouvel agrément est
long
se déroule sur une année l'idée était
donc de dire que cette mesure devrait
entrer en vigueur au plus tard au moment
du réagrément qui suivra soit en 2028
mais rien n'empêche de demander au
gouvernement de s'engager à impulser ce
changement avant cette date pour qu'on
attend la position du gouvernement mais
chez nous c'est un avis défavorable
merci monsieur chevrollier monsieur le
ministre à vis du gouvernement
avis défavorable du gouvernement je mets
donc au voile un moment 11 qui reçoit
deux avis défavorables qui et pour qui
et pour qui comptent qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adoptée je me vois l'article
12 qui pour quiconque qui s'abstient
elle est adoptée après l'article 12 un
moment 43 présentée par miss et fernique
la présidente donc cet amendement
d'appel encourage l'expérimentation
territoriale sur la base du volontariat
de dispositifs de consignes de certains
équipements numériques afin de favoriser
le réemploi le recyclage ou leur
réutilisation
sans vous tous aujourd'hui dans le
domaine de l'économie circulaire la
réduction des déchets et le
développement de la valorisation des
équipements numériques apparaissent
comme une priorité à étudier et à
expérimenter l'établir sur la base du
volontariat et à l'échelle des
collectivités territoriales semble mieux
adaptées afin de déterminer quels
procédés de recyclage fonctionne le
mieux
à ce titre la consignation de certains
équipements numériques afin d'accroître
le taux de collecte des équipements
réemployables avant qu'ils ne perdent
leur valeur d usage et deviennent les
déchets serait un progrès notable dans
la réduction de l'empreinte carbone en
rallongeant la durée de vie des produits
en réduisant les déchets d'équipements
électriques et électroniques
si chers collègues de la commission
merci madame la présidente donc cet
amendement prévoit que des
expérimentations peuvent être lancés sur
la base du volontariat par les
collectivités pour développer des
dispositifs de consignes pour certains
équipements numériques en premier lieu
les collectivités peuvent
d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui prévoir ce
type de mesure soit par exemple en
partenariat avec des entreprises ou avec
l'éco organisme en charge de la collecte
de ces équipements soient par exemple
par un système de gratification que rien
ne leur interdit à ce jour de déployer
en outre pour ce qui est de la consigne
à proprement parler comme le prévoit
l'amendement son utilité n'est pas
forcément avérée pour des produits qui
ont encore de la valeur marchande comme
les téléphones portables par exemple qui
sont davantage captée par la filière
économique du réemploi et ce sujet
d'ailleurs avait déjà été traité par le
biais du rapport blandin longeau il y a
maintenant donc quelques années donc
c'est un avis défavorable par un merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre mais il y en à la présidente
l'avis défavorable je mets au voilà
maintenant 43 qui vient de se retirer
après l'article 12 1 44 rectifiée
présentée par monsieur fernique tout à
fait donc cet amendement donc vise à
proposer au gouvernement d'élaborer une
étude d'impact et de faisabilité afin
d'améliorer le recyclage le réemploi et
la réutilisation des équipements
numériques actuellement très peu recyclé
j'ai dit on regarde la complexité de
mise en oeuvre de tels dispositifs mais
également de la nécessité de réduire le
gaspillage et les déchets des
équipements numériques il est essentiel
d'évaluer toutes les solutions
envisageables pour le réemploi
ce rapport pourrait étudier la
possibilité mise en place on en a parlé
de consignation d'équipements numériques
il pourrait étudier l'opportunité de
mise en oeuvre de passeports produits
c'est-à-dire d'un dispositif
d'identification unique de l'équipement
permettant d'assurer la traçabilité et
la disponibilité d'informations sur les
caractéristiques des produits de
comptabiliser le flux de réemploi ou
reconditionnement en parallèle du flux
de recyclage à ce titre dans son plan
d'économies actions d'économie
circulaire pour une europe plus propre
et plus compétitive
la commission européenne annonce la mise
en place de passeports numériques
enfin ce rapport pour être étudiés
l'installation l'élargissement d'un
dispositif de collecte des déchets
d'équipements électriques ou
électroniques dans certains magasins
donc une étude sur la faisabilité de
mise en oeuvre de tous ces dispositifs
il paraît très opportune pour une mise
en oeuvre efficace du recyclage des
équipements numériques
merci sa collègue monsieur chevrolet
avis de la commission
merci madame la présidente ou proposer
un rapport sur le recyclage le réemploi
et la réutilisation des équipements
numériques
la question de la structuration d'une
filière de recyclage des terminaux
numériques ainsi que les enjeux de
développement du réemploi et de la
réutilisation ces biens sont essentiels
pour limiter le renouvellement excessif
une fois n'est pas coutume nous vous
proposons un avis favorable
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
la présidente
il nous semble que le sujet pardon de
lucky est évoquée aujourd'hui à travers
cet amendement a déjà été abordé lors de
l'examen de la loi
hajek avec une mesure concrète de primes
retour plus adapté aux équipements
numériques plutôt que de consigne qui
n'est pas adapté à ce type d'équipement
en raison de la durée de vie de ces
produits ne sont anti favorable on est
au 44 rectifier
rattrapé par
très bien merci monsieur le ministre je
mets au voilà moment 44 rectifie car
reçu un avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
article 13 à un amendement 32 il est
présenté par monsieur gilles et merci
madame la présidente
la commission a adopté un amendement du
groupe socialiste dont l'objectif est de
faire de l'achat public un levier pour
réduire l'empreinte carbone du numérique
ainsi le texte de la proposition de loi
inscrit désormais la politique d'achat
dans une démarche de durabilité des
produits et de sobriété numérique dans
le cadre des schémas de promotion des
achats publics socialement
écologiquement responsable ces schémas
sont actuellement applicables aux
collectivités dont le montant annuel d
achat dépasse le seuil de 100 millions
d'euros hors taxes de fait
cette obligation concerne uniquement les
très grandes collectivités et donc selon
bercy seuls 160 organisations seraient
concernées par cette obligation qui est
quand même relativement peu pourtant la
forme de ce schéma est libre et peut
s'appuyer sur le plan national d'action
pour les achats publics durables une
nouvelle version de ce plan est
d'ailleurs annoncée pour début 2011 21
comme l'a rappelé le commissariat
général au développement durable au 10
décembre dernier l'achat public doit
jouer un rôle clé et vertueux dans la
relance la commande publique doit
intégrer davantage de durabilité
davantage d'enjeux sociaux et
environnementaux croire un effet plus
transformant par ailleurs la feuille de
route présentée en 2018 par le
gouvernement pour l'économie circulaire
proposition 44 prévoit d'abaisser le
seuil à partir duquel devient
obligatoire le schéma de promotion des
achats publics socialement
écologiquement responsables ainsi notre
amendement propose de concrétiser cette
mesure en introduisant un seuil légal
fixé un montant total annuel des achats
à 75 millions d'euros au lieu des 100
millions d'euros actuellement fixée par
arrêté voilà donc le sens de notre
amendement qui devrait inciter davantage
de collectivités à s'interroger sur leur
stratégie d'achat et intégré l'enjeu de
durabilité des produits de sobriété
numérique
si monsieur j les avis de la commission
monsieur hooligans merci madame la
présidente en effet monsieur gilles et
donc la commission en décembre dernier
adopté un amendement du groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
visant à inclure les enjeux de
durabilité des produits et de sobriété
numérique dans les schémas de promotion
des achats publics responsables
bonjour aujourd'hui ces schémas doivent
être élaborées par les collectivités
comme vous l'avez indiqué dont le
montant annuel total des achats et
supérieur un montant fixé par voie
réglementaire 100 millions d'euros la
pertinence de ce seuil qui est
particulièrement élevé se pose en effet
vous l'avez souligné le gouvernement a
indiqué au moment des débats que nous
avions pendant la loi à gec que la
révision du plan national d'action pour
des achats durables qui devait être
prévue pour fin 2020 serait l'occasion
de mener une réflexion d'ensemble sur
l'organisation de ces schémas et la
pertinence d'un nouveau seuil donc ce le
ministre est ce que le gouvernement
s'est engagé dans cette voie ce que vous
nous apportez des des réponses est ce
que ce seuil sera t'il abaissé par voie
réglementaire comme cela devait être le
cas en vertu du droit actuel donc nous
apparaît pour nous un peu délicat de
fixer ce type de seuil dans la loi est
peut-être le gouvernement est en mesure
de nous apporter des réponses sur cette
question dont nous souhaitons avoir la
vie dure et gloucester gillet j'ai une
réponse au fond qui est un peu une
réponse d'attentes cave il y a tout
impact et un paquet est liée aux marchés
publics dans le projet de loi
10 de la convention citoyenne des
déclinaisons des propositions de la com
en système qui doit être présenté en
février par le gouvernement est dans ce
cadre que nous voulons présenter les
dispositifs de nature législative est de
nature réglementaire qui ont vocation à
traduire les demandes de la convention
citoyenne
s'agissant de du projet d'amendement du
sénateur j'ai il nous semble que pour le
coup cela relève du niveau réglementaire
et que donc
voilà ce n'est pas du niveau législatif
en tout état de cause la réponse au fond
vous sera apportée dans le cadre de la
combe du pour les lois convention
citoyenne dans les semaines qui viennent
mais il y aura bien une partie relative
aux marchés publics
donc il est retiré par message il est
donc l'amendement 32 et retiré
je mets aux voix l'article 13 à qui et
pour qui contre sap si elle est adoptée
article 13 le 6 rectifié monsieur gold
le présent merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'état et ses services ces collectivités
territoriales et leurs groupements
doivent se montrer exemplaire en matière
environnementale
c'est pourquoi nous sommes très
favorables à ce que les achats publics
tiennent compte des critères de
répétabilité à court terme puis de
durabilité à moyen terme pour
l'acquisition de leurs produits
numériques
'l'indice de réparabilité est entrée en
vigueur depuis le 1er janvier 2021
certes toutes les entreprises ne sont
pas prêtes à disposer d'un an pour
s'adapter
cependant afin d'assiter inciter ces
dernières à adopter le plus rapidement
cet indice il nous semble utile d'avancé
de six mois l'application de cet article
tel est l'objet du présent amendement
collègues mais c'est ce volet avis de la
commission
oui merci mais là le présidente la
commission a fait le choix de laisser un
an d'application de ces nouveaux indices
afin d'en faire des critères de la
commande publique notamment pour une
meilleure appropriation par les acteurs
prévoir le 30 juin 2021 au lieu du 1er
janvier 2022 pour la 10 réparabilité qui
vient d'entrer en vigueur au 1er janvier
réduire est le délai de six mois nous
pensons qu'il convient de laisser un an
pour avoir un retour sur le
fonctionnement et la mise en place de
cet indice est donc un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre mes avis
défavorable je mets au il est retiré
et donc un rendement 6 rectifié retirer
je me vois l'article 13 qui et pour qui
est content qu'ils s'abstiennent il est
adopté article 14
un moment c'est rectifié monsieur gold
is chers collègues nous connaissons le
sort des amendements relatifs à
l'application de taux de tva réduit en
effet nous avons tenté à plusieurs
reprises d'abaisser le taux de tva des
services de réparation tout en ayant
conscience des difficultés que posent
actuellement l'annexé iii de la
directive tva du 28 novembre 2006 qui
établit une liste limitative des biens
et services pouvant en bénéficier
toutefois la brèche étant ouverte par la
proposition de loi nous proposons
d'élargir le bénéfice du taux réduit de
tva à 5,5 aux produits issus du réemploi
la réutilisation ainsi qu'au service de
mise à disposition de l' usage des biens
moyennant facturation c'est à dire des
biens issus d'économie la fonctionnalité
si une négociation doit avoir lieu dans
le cadre de la révision des directives
européennes 2006 en la matière elle doit
permettre d'envoyer un signal prix
positif au bénéfice de ses biens plus
vertueux qui permettront de limiter
l'impact environnemental du numérique
merci monsieur gold le sualg à l'avis de
la commission
merci madame la présidente donc
l'article 14 de la proposition de loi
donc prévoit une tva réduite pour
l'acquisition de produits électriques et
électroniques reconditionnés et pour les
services de réparation de biens
comportant des éléments numériques donc
la mission d'information dans ce texte
est issu en effet considéré que de tels
taux de tva réduit pourrait contribuer à
renforcer l'attractivité des offres
issues du reconditionnement et de la
réparation et ainsi limiter le
renouvellement des terminaux
en conséquence il participerait
également la structuration dans les
territoires d'un écosystème industrielle
du reconditionnement et de la réparation
mais comme vous l'avez souligné nous
sommes conscients qu'en l'état actuel du
droit européen
une telle modification se heurte à
l'impossibilité pour les états membres
de fixer un taux réduit pour des biens
et des services qui ne figure pas dans
la nex de la directive tva alors
conscience cette limite nous avons
malgré tout souhaité inscrire cet
article afin de définir une position du
sénat en faveur d'une telle évolution
dans le cadre de
de la révision en cours de cette
directive puis de souhaiter bon courage
aux négociateurs donc mais cette limite
rend difficile l'élargissement d'une
telle disposition donc c'est
malheureusement un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
mini ce même avis oui madame la
présidente
le rapporteur et le sénateur goal
l'union fait l'argumentaire
d'inconventionnalité à la place jeudi du
gouvernement est juste pour rappeler que
et de dire très officiellement même si
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire en
commission que la position du
gouvernement français
porté par barbares pompili dans les
cénacles européen est bien d'avoir une
modèle de moduler les taux de tva pour
le reconditionner de faire en sorte
qu'ils aient bien une tva réduite sur
ces objets là mais c'est du niveau
communautaire
donc nous sont défavorables à l'artiste
et par extension à l'amendement merci
monsieur le ministre je mets au voile 7
il est retiré retirer je mets aux voix
l'article 14 qui et pour qui et contre
kiev saïd effet adopté après l'article
keith vraiment 58 rectifié monsieur mort
est oui merci mme la présidente cet
amendement dans le prolongement de
l'amendement que j'ai présentée tout à
l'heure et qui a été adoptée vise à
favoriser la confiance du consommateur
dans la qualité des produits
reconditionnés et donc ils proposent que
l''indice de durabilité qui a été créée
par la loi contre le gaspillage et pour
l'économie circulaire indices qui doit
entrer en application le 1er janvier
2000 24 ne s'applique pas seulement aux
produits neufs mais également aux
produits reconditionnés là encore pour
améliorer la confiance des consommateurs
dans les produits reconditionnés
collègues avis la commission mais se
sauvera dit oui merci mais la présidente
l'application de l'indicent de
durabilité aux produits reconditionnés
pourrait avoir plus d'inconvénients que
davantage il s'agirait pour chaque
produits reconditionnés de procéder à
une analyse de sa durabilité afin de
déterminer le niveau de l' indice ce qui
pourrait s'avérer particulièrement lourd
et constituer un frein au développement
de ses activités de réemploi il est par
ailleurs permis de douter les avantages
qui découlerait d'un tel dispositif les
consommateurs privilégiant la kiss
d'un terminé reconditionnés sont souvent
conscients du meilleur bilan
environnemental du reconditionnés par
rapport à l'achat du terminal 9 il n'est
donc pas certain que l'application de la
indices de durabilité aux produits
reconditionnés conduisent à une plus
forte attractivité de ses produits
nous partageons en revanche votre
préoccupation concernant la confiance
des consommateurs dans les bières
reconditionnés c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons émis toute heure un
avis favorable à votre amendement
tendant à renforcer la traçabilité donc
pour cet amendement par contre nous
demandons un retrait sinon un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre mais lui même avis je mets au
voile amendement 58 rectifie car reçu
deux avis défavorables qui est pour et
qui est contre
je vais rue de procéder au vote si vous
pouviez bien lever les mains qui est
pour
ces bons qui est contre
10 abstient il est adopté
après l'article 14
un amendement 41 rectifié quater
présentée par monsieur chaize mais la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues mais présente amendement
vise à rendre explicite l'exclusion de
l'obligation des rémunération pour copie
privée les produits reconditionnés dont
les smartphones des ordinateurs et ont
déjà fait l'objet d'une première mise
sur le marché en europe
en effet le paiement de la rémunération
pour copie privée est collectée sur les
produits nov
lors de la mise en circulation en europe
or un produit ne peut faire l'objet que
d'une seule mise en circulation au sens
de l'article
1245 4 du code civil ainsi cette
rémunération devrait pouvoir s'appliquer
aux produits reconditionnés qui
proviennent d'europe puisque la
redevance ne doit être payée qu'une
seule fois sur un même produit
en outre l'application de ces
obligations aux produits reconditionnés
ferait peser une menace sur un secteur
en développement et apportant une
contribution majeure à l'essor d'une
économie numérique plus circulaire et
plus vertueuse
enfin si ces produits numériques
reconditionnés devait être soumis à
cette redevance
le coût supplémentaire serait supportée
par les consommateurs eux mêmes et
pourrait favoriser l'achat de produits
neufs à faible coût mais de moindre
qualité technique et de plus fort impact
environnemental plutôt que l'achat de
produire au gros 10 youn et en europe
cela provoquerait un double coup en ces
temps de crise une perte de pouvoir
d'achat pour les français est un frein
développement des solutions
environnementales vertueuse merci
monsieur chaize avis de la commission le
rapporteur
merci madame la présidente donc cet
amendement comme l'a souligné monsieur
chaize visa exonérés du paiement de la
rémunération pour copie privée les
équipements numériques reconditionnés
qui sont issus de produits ayant déjà
fait l'objet d'une première mise sur le
marché en europe et qui ont déjà donné
lieu à ce titre à une telle rémunération
pour l'heure selon les informations dont
nous disposons les biens reconditionnés
n'ont jamais fait l'objet de
prélèvements à ce jour au titre de la
rémunération pour copie privée
pour autant nous avons appris que cela
était envisagé par la commission qui est
chargée de déterminer les types de
supports qui entrent dans le champ de la
rémunération
il nous semble donc qu'un amendement
exonérant les biens reconditionnés du
paiement de la rémunération pour copie
privée ne conduirait pas à une perte de
recettes pour le monde de la culture
à ce jour il s'agit tout au plus d'une
perte de recettes hypothétique alors la
question se pose de façon nous de faire
débat est il pertinent que les biens
reconditionnés contribuer au financement
d'activités culturelles
il nous semble que répondent par
l'affirmative à cette question serait
quelque peu contradictoire avec les
objectifs de la proposition de loi et
monsieur chaize la développer dans son
amendement
on ne peut pas vouloir stimuler l'essor
des activités de reconditionnement
objectif que nous partageons tous dans
cet hémicycle est acceptée dans le même
temps que ses activités soient taxés ce
n'est pas un sujet anecdotique pour les
reconditionneurs l'application de la
rémunération pour copie privée à un
smartphone de 250 euros pourrait
conduire selon nos informations à un
prélèvement d'environ 10 euros
autrement dit cet assujettissement à nu
leur est presque intégralement la baisse
des taux de tva sur les biens
reconditionnés que nous avons souhaité à
l'article 14 de plus il faut noter que
cet amendement n'empêcherait pas le
prélèvement sur les biens reconditionnés
en dehors des frontières européennes
l'exonération ne porterait en effet que
sur les biens reconditionnés dans les
smartphones et ordinateurs ont déjà fait
l'objet d'une première mise sur le
marché en europe
l'amendement permettront permettrait
donc de renforcer la compétitivité des
activités de reconditionnement nationale
et européenne
aux dépens du reconditionnement
extra-européens donc c'est donc un avis
favorable
considérant que selon les informations
dont nous disposons les biens roudour
reconditionnés n'ont jamais fait l'objet
de prélèvements à ce jour au titre de la
rémunération pour copie privée et nous
aimerions bien avoir la confirmation de
monsieur le ministre sur ce point merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre à vis du gouvernement
bon madame la présidente sur ceux de
cette discussion qui effectivement fait
fait débat je confirme monsieur le
rapporteur qu' à ce stade et compte tenu
de l'évaluation juridique qui a été
faite de la taxe copie privée les biens
reconditionnés aujourd'hui ne paye pas
cette taxe copie privée
la commission copie privée estiment
qu'ils auraient dû la payer il ya un
débat juridique c'est pour le moins
contestable en tout état de cause la
question qui s'est posée aujourd'hui
était de savoir
doit-on faire rémunérer par les
appareils reconditionnés donc augmenter
la taxation sur leurs et conditionner
cette taxe copie privée
il y avait deux visions qui aujourd'hui
encore deux visions qui s'opposent une
vision plutôt favorable reconditionnés
et à la réutilisation qui nous dit ils
ont déjà payé ces appareils ont déjà
payé cet axe puisqu'ils ont déjà été
acquis et donc ils ont payé à ce moment
là une taxe copie privée
une autre vision qui considère que
compte tenu de l'effet de l'allongement
de durée de la vie qui est effectivement
les faits chercher et que par l'effet de
transmission de propriété il y avait
lieu de faire payer cette taxe copie
privée donc avec jusqu'ici deux visions
qui s'opposent est une qui considérait
qu'il fallait l'exonérer complètement et
l'autre qu'il considérait qu'il fallait
assujettir complètement les produits
reconditionnés à cette taxe copie privée
je trouve que la proposition en tout cas
c'est une position personnelle la
proposition faite par les sénateurs
chaise faisait relativement sens en
considérant que les produits
reconditionnés en france avec déjà payé
la taxe puisqu'il avait déjà été acquis
et que les produits par contre
reconditionnés réimporter depuis l'asie
ne l'avait jamais payé puisqu'il n'avait
pas été acquis une première fois dans
leur état neuf en ordre et donc d'une
certaine manière il y avait une
possibilité d'échappatoire offerte par
le sénateur chef mais puisqu'il vient
mais dans cette histoire ce n'est pas
l'affection du gouvernement et donc
étant solidaire de la position du
gouvernement je serais défavorable à cet
art cette proposition d'amendement
disney cherchait ce merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole à madame darcos
la madame darcos d'abord manandhar cause
pour explication de vote ensuite
monsieur chaize merci beaucoup un
président on voit bien que en effet
monsieur le ministre vous avez un petit
peu de mal en effet à avoir donné un
avis qui est contraire à vos convictions
mais j'ai la cgil a confirmé c'est une
confirmation tout à l'heure de la part
du ministère de la culture qu'il ya déjà
des sociétés qui ont payé cette
rémunération pour copie privée puisque
la loi elles existent monsieur le
rapporteur
donc la loi existe et elle s'applique
pour l'instant également aux appareils
conditionné reconditionnés il s'agit pas
en fait de faire payer de nouveaux
assujettir deux fois aux mêmes appareils
cette rémunération mais ces appareils
reconditionnés vont avoir
potentiellement une deuxième vie et donc
avec un noah nouvelle at-il isat heures
et avec toutes les fonctionnalités de
d'origine
ce manque à gagner qui est calculée par
le ministère de la culture et par les
acteurs et de 20 millions d'euros
alors ce que m'avait dit ce qu on a
discuté quand même avec monsieur chaize
puisque nous sommes amis depuis deux
jours nous échangeons beaucoup sur cette
question quand quand vous aviez sais pas
ce que ça donnait très chaud depuis deux
jours mais sinon discutons toujours de
bonnes comme de camaraderie
c'était en effet à ce moment là puisque
c'est sur deux ans pourquoi pas 100 la
doubler en effet la taxe des départs
comme ces appareils et ses traits
verture jour je salue tout à fait les
initiatives qui sont faits dans cette
dans cette proposition de loi
si on doit avoir une vie pour ses
smartphones de plus de deux ans mais de
quatre ou cinq ans à ce moment-là
doublons doublons la taxe parce que si
vous voulez pour les et pour les ayants
droit
c'est deux vies différentes et ils ne
sont finalement sans pénaliser sur cette
deuxième vie c'est 20 millions d'euros
sur les ayants droits culturels et en ce
moment où la culture en a besoin
je crois que ça serait vraiment vraiment
un très mauvais signal donc c'est déjà
fait il ya certes un certain société qui
préfère aller au contentieux
mais ces sociétés qui ont payé et donc
c'est un vrai manque à gagner merci
darcos me suis mombelli pour explication
de vote et il se fait ensuite la
présidente merci moi j'ai cosigné cette
amende non et je le vois très bien
évidemment pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que les structures ont
effectivement sur ces appareils financés
et si je fais le parallèle avec l'éco
participation l'éco-contribution on la
demande pas deux fois
l'objectif de ces contributions et vos
participations c'est de financer
justement le recyclage de l'objet et
donc si on vient à chaque fois rajouté
la taxe à voir ça c'est le premier
argument le second c'est que un appareil
issus du réemploi ou du recyclage
il a un coût pour un modèle par exemple
à 256 giga dont avec une marque je ne
citerai pas s'appeller en termes de prix
d'achat neuf aller jusqu'à 1500 euros
un appareil reconditionnés à 506 vous
impliquer cette taxe qui est fixe à
quatre roses façon pour 1 256 giga en
pourcentage savait pas la même chose
quand on est du simple au triple sur le
coût d'acquisition et donc moi ce que je
propose parce qu'il faut bien faire des
propositions
à l'instar de ce que vient de dire notre
collègue laure darcos c'est que la
contribution elle soit plus forte sur le
produit neuf ce qui créera un écart
encore plus important et incitera et
rendra plus attractif le prêt d'un
appareil reconditionnés mais dans des
proportions non pas doublé mais si on
veut compenser les 20 millions qui sont
évoqués il faut simplement l'augmenter
de 10% de 8% même cette contribution sur
l'appareil neuf donc je pense que ce
serait beaucoup plus judicieux que de
taxer un appareil reconditionnés notre
objectif c'est de rendre plus attaque
plus attractif
un appareil reconditionnés et bien
taxons si nécessaire pour le monde de la
culture à hauteur de 8% supplémentaires
sur les 4 euros 60 pour un appareil neuf
et le problème est résolu sans pour
autant taxés des appareils air
conditionné merci messieurs willi
monsieur chaize mais maintenant la
présidente monsieur ministre merci de
m'en donner la parole juste pour évoquer
le fait que en fait cet amendement il
n'a pas de vocation évidemment à venir
embêter le monde de la culture bien au
contraire et que dans les propos de ma
collègue laure darcos
on retrouve effectivement je crois le
l'aspect fondamental du sujet c'est que
il faut que cette taxe peut-être soirée
claire et équilibrée mais c'est pas dans
le cas de ce texte qu'on pourra ré qu'il
y aurait cette taxe dans le cas de ce
texte il est important de montrer que
l'ambition est que le recyclage puisse
permette de donner une vie plus longue
ah ah ces matériels donc parce que c'est
un objectif qui a été exprimée et qui a
été identifié dans le cadre de nos
travaux et faire en sorte éventuellement
de retravailler sur la taxe dans un
autre contexte
moi je voudrais quand même revenir sur
le point qui consiste à dire que on peut
pas sur un même matériel
parce que c'est un même matériel qui
certes a été rénové un moment donné
faire en sorte que on reprenne
une taxe c'est à dire si on prend un
comparatif avec d'autres sujets on
pourrait imaginer que sur bien enfin sur
un bien immobilier qui a payé sa taxe
d'aménagement
à l'origine de sa construction et bien
après restauration de ce bien et revente
on demande à l'acheteur de repayer la
taxe d'aménagement
personne ne pourra l admettre et c'est à
peu près le même le même principe que
aujourd'hui on défense sur le sujet des
smartphones donc voilà je les chats
collègues ce que je voulais exprimer
pour bien que vous ayez en tête
l'enjeu en fait de s'étendre et cher
collègue la parole et havana brulin pour
explication de vote
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre nous nous voterons contre cet
amendement
[Musique]
je rejoins les arguments qui ont été
développées par notre collègue laure
darcos
et puis les chiffres qui ont été données
par d'autres collègues qui sont tout à
fait justes ne démontre absolument pas
je trouve qu'avec cette taxe les
appareils reconditionnés devrait
deviendrait moins attractifs les
chiffres que vous avez données montrent
qu'ils le resteraient complètement
attractif par rapport à des appareils
neufs
j'entends que chacun cherche et qui a
peut-être d'autres pistes qui peuvent
être réfléchie vers un rééquilibrage
mais comme on dit parfois il ya le texte
il ya le contexte nous débattons de ce
sujet au moment même où les acteurs
culturels sont dans la plus grande
difficulté et où cette rémunération pour
copie privée est absolument essentiel
dans le moment qu'ils vivent
parce que pour certains d'entre eux
c'est la seule rémunération actuelle et
donc je crois que le sénat dans sa
sagesse devrait aussi prendre en compte
ces éléments là on doit ouvrir le débat
on doit y réfléchir j'entends mais nous
sommes dans un moment où même si c'est
un manque à gagner ce serait extrêmement
mauvais signal à donner que de dire que
nous ne voulons pas le donner pour
soutenir le monde de la culture je vous
remercie
dame brune la parole est à metz et
gilles et oui nous voyons bien que ce
débat est quand même particulièrement
utile parce que il ya quand même une
forme de hiatus qui aujourd'hui n'est
pas définitivement traité entre la perte
financière d'un côté qui est constaté
puisqu'on parle de compensation d'une
part et d'autre part la durabilité d'un
produit et du fait de sa durabilité ya
forcément une durabilité d'usagé et qui
dit usage dit aussi une forme
d'exploitation ensuite de donner ou de
[Musique]
sources à caractère culturel et donc
c'est bien un peu ces confrontations qui
pose question aujourd'hui est
effectivement dans le contexte actuel ça
paraît peut-être un peu délicat de
prendre cette décision
aujourd'hui sans avoir des éléments
suffisamment certain quant à la
compensation financière qui pourrait
être trouvé donc je pense qu'il faut
avoir une certaine prudence même si on
comprend
l'origine de cet amendement est pour
notre part on propose un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur gilles et je vais mettre
aux voix le moment 41 rectifié quater
qu'elle reçoit un avis favorable de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour
d'accord qui contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas il est
adopté par lhenry il est adopté
jamais on voit l'article 14 bis qui pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté l article 15
nous avons deux amendements identiques
de suppression faisant l'objet de
discussion commune est tout d'abord
présentation du 8 rectifier et c'est un
madame carrère qui s'y colle merci
madame la présidente mes chers collègues
les réseaux ne représente que 5 % de
l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique
nous entendons que ce chiffre peut
évoluer malgré des progrès considérables
et rapides réalisés par le secteur et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
proposition de loi propose la
possibilité de supprimer les forfaits
mobiles avec un accès aux données
mobiles illimités d'un côté des faits de
cet article sur l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique sera
marginal alors qu'il sera bien réelle
pour les ménages précaires et pour nos
concitoyens qui ne disposent pas d'une
connexion fixe wifi cette mesure sera
indolore pour les ménages les plus aisés
ce qui réduira son efficacité alors que
la couverture en très haut débit
s'améliore progressivement que nos
concitoyens accède enfin à la 4g dans
cette ère certaines territoire en leur
seraient payés plus chèrement leur
forfait le groupe rdse s'oppose à cet
article inéquitable susceptible de
creuser la fracture numérique de
surcroît nous rejoignons la position de
l'ancien président de l'arcep
monsieur sébastien soriano pour qui je
le cite la nécessaire sobriété du
numérique ne doit pas s'entendre comme
la limitation des échanges en ligne
la crise a montré combien ces échanges
étaient cruciaux à la vie de la nation
est nulle autorité ne pourrait s'ériger
en juges des bons ou des mauvais usage
dans la démocratie
la profusion d'internet doit rester une
source inépuisable de vitalité
d'expression et d'innovation il ne
s'agit donc pas de dire qu'il ne faut
rien faire face à l'augmentation de la
demande de la consommation des données
mais nous préférons privilégier
pédagogie à la contrainte et à
l'application d'une disposition
pénalisante pour l'ensemble des
utilisateurs sans égard pour le contexte
de l'utilisation des réseaux mobiles
pour toutes ces raisons nous proposons
donc la suppression de cet article je
vous remercier si madame carrère la
parole et a maintenant pour l'amendement
numéro 12 c'est madame varaillas qui le
présente de privilégier des modalités
tarification des forfaits mobiles
incitant les consommateurs à favoriser
une connexion filaire ou par accès wifi
à une connexion impliquant une
consommation de données mobiles celui ci
est donc censé s'articuler avec
l'artiste 13 de la loi l'eec qui prévoit
que les consommateurs soient informés
dès 2022 de la quantité de données
consommées des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre correspondance cette
consommation
très concrètement l'entrée en
application de l'article engagerait une
pénalisation des consommateurs en
fonction de leur consommation
nous considérons pour notre part et
c'est d'ailleurs la base de la colère
des gilets jaunes il faut bien le dire
qu'il convient d'articuler justice
environnementale sociale et fiscale
ainsi la voie de la pénalisation
financière pour en appeler à des
comportements écologiquement vertus et
ne nous semble un chemin nous sommes un
chemin acceptable pour nous constitue à
toi hien a fortiori en pleine crise
ducobu 19 alors que nombre d'entre eux
doivent faire face à des difficultés
financières accrues
nous proposons donc la suppression de
cet article qui n'a pas sa place dans
cette proposition de loi ou du moins
nous pensons qu'il n'a pas sa place dans
cette proposition de loi
merci sa collègue alors nous façon
l'avis de la commission et se relier sur
ces deux amendements identiques
voyez merci à la présidente dans notre
rapport de juin 2020 nous avions proposé
que ce instaurer une tarification des
forfaits plus ou moins proportionnelle
aux données mobiles fixées par l'offre
pourquoi avons nous choisi d'aller dans
cette direction
nous avions constaté que les réseaux
mobiles sont beaucoup plus énergivore
que les réseaux fixes le simple
visionnage d'une vidéo en 4g est quatre
fois plus consommateurs qu un visionnage
en wifi je rappelle aussi que les
consommateurs des réseaux mobiles sont
en grande partie proportionnel aux
usages qui en sont faits ce n'est pas le
cas des réseaux fixes ces réalités sont
souvent méconnu des français
elle explique pourtant en grande partie
l'explosion du trafic de données mobiles
+ 30 % par an qui jouera un rôle
important dans l'accroissement
considérable des impacts
environnementaux des réseaux mis en
avant par notre rapport d'information je
rappelle que la consommation énergétique
des réseaux pourrait croître de 75%
d'ici 2040 des forfaits mobiles dont la
tarification serait totalement décorrélé
des données mobiles consommer nous nous
sommes donc pas souhaitable car il
annuler totalement le message qui
pourrait être adressées aux
consommateurs de privilégier une
connexion wifi à une connexion mobile
notons également que ces forfaits
constitue un billet tarifaire en faveur
des plus gros consommateurs aux dépens
des plus petits consommateurs qui
correspondent souvent catégories de
revenus les plus modestes
on sait en effet que les personnes à
revenus modestes n'ont souvent pas les
moyens de souscrire à des forfaits avec
des plafonds élevé de données ou des
forfaits illimités
ce constat est en fait nous avons
finalement préféré dans le cadre de
cette proposition loi laisser les
opérateurs trouver les modalités
notamment tarifaires pour inciter les
consommateurs à privilégier une
connexion wifi les engagements
contraignants que les opérateurs devront
prendre sur le fondement de l'article 23
de la proposition pour notamment inclure
une tarification des forfaits mobiles
plus incitative
c'est le sens de cet article 15 qui nous
semble équilibré en somme nous sommes
passés d'une obligation de moyens à une
obligation de résultat ce qui est tout à
fait dans l'esprit de la proposition
doit aussi nous sommes défavorable aux
amendements de suppression numéro 8 et
12 à l'article 15
merci monsieur chevrollier monsieur le
ministre à vis du gouvernement
oui madame la présidente c'est un des
sujets sur lesquels nous avions pas mal
débattu lorsque nous étions en
commission il nous semble qu'il y a lieu
de continuer la discussion que nous ne
sommes pas totalement arrivé à maturité
nous sommes favorable jeudi à la
suppression de l'article 15
en l'état je crois que nous comprenons
l'objectif qui était proposée proposé
par le texte initial qui est d'envoyer
un signal sur une consommation
supérieure de données nous sommes que le
sujet n'a pas totalement à terry ne
serait ce que parce qu'aujourd'hui dans
les faits en fait vous ne payez rien
quand vous êtes en wifi lorsque vous
êtes avec votre puisqu'on a des comptes
par votre consommation de données avec
votre le forfait d'ailleurs vous pouvez
probablement utiliser votre téléphone
portable sans forfait lorsque vous êtes
en wifi bon en tout cas on comprend
l'objectif les choses ont évolué depuis
la première rédaction il me semble que
les choses ne sont pas encore mûrs et
donc nous vous proposons de poursuivre
la discussion dans le cadre de la
navette parlementaire et donc dans
l'attenté nous seront favorables à la
suppression de l article 15
merci monsieur le ministre
oui c'est évidemment un article
important de ce travail collectif
je crois qu'il ya une erreur d' analyse
de penser que le forfait illimité
profite aux ménages modestes celle
inverse
c'est totalement l'inversé le forfait
illimité c'est une machine infernale
forfait illimité ça veut dire que ceux
qui font des offres de programmes des
offres de service ou toujours intérêt à
proposer l'offre de service la plus
performante sans regarder du tout
la quantité de data derrière ça amène à
la situation que nous connaissons de
devoir investir en urgence sur la 5g en
tout cas ça nous est expliqué comme ça
alors qu'on a encore des territoires qui
sont très loin de la 3g parce que
monsieur lui je vous ai entendu tout à
l'heure avec votre exemple
d'agriculteurs bretons qui probablement
pour capter au moins la 4g
pour pouvoir optimiser ces pesticides
mais nous on préférerait qu'il passe en
bio il optimiserait encore plus mais
surtout moi je peux vous dire qu à
gourin cet été je pouvais pas envoyé un
texto dans le centre-ville et que
finalement le fait qu' on est des
forfaits illimités fait qu'on a toujours
besoin de tuyaux plus gros ça va comme
l'a très bien dit le rapporteur un
chevreau lié à mener à une explosion des
consommation énergétique liée aussi aux
réseaux même si aujourd'hui c'est moins
que pour les terminaux et la machine ne
s'arrêtera pas la machine ne s'arrêtera
pas plus d'investissements ça veut dire
que demain tous les forfaits seront plus
chers parce qu'il va falloir payer en
permanence cet investissement donc c'est
une erreur majeure de ne pas s'attaquer
aux forfaits illimités et ça sera contre
les territoires les plus fragiles et
contre les ménages modestes donc
socialement il faut s'attaquer aux
forfaits illimités
si monsieur dompter que monsieur chaize
pour explication merci madame la
présidente juste peut-être pourrait
expliquer l'origine de ce ces articles
on a vécu
collectivement le 15 mars un confinement
à cette occasion j'ai pu suivre avec
l'ensemble des opérateurs ce qui se
passait sur le terrain
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur le
terrain en deux jours les débits
transiter sur les réseaux ont doublé ce
qui a d'ailleurs créé une petite à dire
crainte voire plus de l'ensemble des
opérateurs et de tout l'écosystème qu'a
proposé la recette
alors j'entends que sébastien soriano a
pris des positions que je ne m'explique
pas mais qu'a proposé l'arcep à ce
moment-là collectivement
l'arcep a dit je vais écouter on va
demander à chacun d'entre nous
de faire en sorte d'utiliser les réseaux
fixes donc la wii fit plus que les
réseaux 4g
on va faire en sorte de demander aux
éditeurs de contenus de limiter les
débits de transit pour passer plutôt en
mode standard plutôt qu'en mode hd
cirque elle qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a
essayé effectivement par l'utilisation
de faire en sorte de limiter les
consommations par le biais des forfaits
illimités
c'est exactement l'objectif qui est
recherché c'est de faire prendre
conscience que en fait un méga c'est un
kilowatt ça une valeur énergétique et
que globalement on ne pourrait pas
aujourd'hui admettre compris dans cette
assemblée que nos forfaits de
consommation électrique soit illimitée
et c'est pourtant c'est ce qu'on est en
train d'admettre sur les forfaits en
date a donc voilà il faut avoir cette
approche de dire chaque fois qu'on ouvre
la possibilité de pouvoir capter du
débit sur les réseaux mobiles
eh bien on donne la capacité en
kilowatts merci monsieur 16 s'il n'y a
plus dans d'explications de vote regret
donc mais trop voir c'est deux
amendements identiques qui on le fait
l'objet d'un avis défavorable de la
commission faveur du gouvernement qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient its ne
sont pas adoptées jeu face à la
présentation de l'amendement un numéro 3
donc hélas c'est monsieur dantec qui le
présente
oui donc cet amendement est la
conséquence logique de la démonstration
nous avons commencé sur le mandement
précédent notamment les propos
extrêmement pertinent de patrick chaize
sur le fait qu' effectivement c'est
quasiment un des seuls domaines où les
gens n'ont pas regardé leur consommation
pour l'eau pour l'électricité pour
l'ensemble des autres domaines on
demande à chacun d'être responsable et
de connaître son impact ici justement il
et pas son impact simplement la
formulation actuelle est quand même
extrêmement timorés parce que peuvent
privilégier dans le peuvent
il y a à peu près toutes les
possibilités je n'ai même pas sûr que
dans la loi les conditionnels sont
vraiment souhaitable et donc pour que la
loi soit beaucoup plus clair
et en écho à la démonstration que nous
venons de faire nous vous proposons donc
de transformer peuvent privilégier par
privilégie qui serait beaucoup plus
clair est totalement cohérent avec la
discussion précédente
si monsieur dantec co2 gâte avec la
commission oui mais pour des raisons qui
ont déjà été précédemment évoqué nous
avons au final souhaitait donc
privilégier une obligation de résultat
une obligation de moyens en ne rendant
pas obligatoire la tarification
proportionnelle aux volumes de données
mobiles et comme le disait mon collègue
guillaume chevrollier de tout à l'heure
c'est à travers l'article 23 où on va
imposer aux opérateurs de souscrire des
engagements contraignants de réduction
des impacts environnementaux que la
régulation va pouvoir s'opérer
donc c'est un avis défavorable merci
mais c'est le ministre à vis du
gouvernement monsieur dantec sur sur le
caractère obligatoire
il me semble que le mot privilégie
laisse quand même un peu de marge
d'appréciation aux opérateurs et que le
peuvent privilégier presque redondant
donc le privilégient laisse quand même
un peu de souplesse et à mon avis était
largement suffisant il ne se doutait que
je mets au voilà moment 3 avec deux avis
défavorables qui pour qui est con cept
elle n'est pas adoptée ce 27 rectifier
il est présenté par madame monsieur
legault merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre
cet amendement vise à compléter une
disposition de la présente ppl prévoyant
que les opérateurs peuvent inciter par
des traces tarifs avantageux
les consommateurs à privilégier la
connexion filaire
or c'est
s'ils se doit d'être assurée sur
l'ensemble du territoire pourtant dans
les zones rurales en particulier il
arrive que cette connexion soit
insuffisante voire endommagé temps sur
les réseaux filaires que les réseaux
cuivre malgré les engagements des
opérateurs à réparer les lignes
défectueuse le présent amendement a donc
pour but de garantir la possibilité pour
tous les consommateurs de se tourner
vers un réseau filaire ou cuivre en bon
état de fonctionnement je vous remercie
merci madame sollogoub monsieur
chevrollier avis de la commission
oui merci mais là la présidente cet
amendement soulève une problématique
très importante celle de la dégradation
du réseau filaire cuivre dont nous avons
tous fait l'expérience d'ailleurs dans
nos territoires il s'agit une situation
qui n'est pas acceptable et qui dit
coupe pour partie du soudan entretien du
réseau cuivre par l'opérateur historique
comme le note très justement cet
amendement la dégradation du réseau fixe
pousse bien souvent nos compatriotes à
se connecter aux réseaux mobiles
beaucoup plus consommateurs d'énergie
pour avoir accès à internet en la
matière un cadre de régulation existe
déjà en tant qu'opérateur historique
orange a été chargé de fournir le
raccordement et le service sur ce réseau
par un arrêté ministériel de novembre
2010 est sur ce fondement l'arcep avait
mis en demeure orange d'améliorer sa
qualité de service sur le réseau cuivre
après avoir constaté une importante
dégradation
l'arcep a depuis salué les efforts
d'orange pour l'amélioration du service
universel nous souhaitons bien entendu
que le régulateur maintienne sa
vigilance en la matière considérant que
cet amendement s'ajoute au cadre
régulatoire existantes donnant un
retrait ou un avis défavorable
tout en reconnaissant que malgré des
mises en demeure d'orange la réalité sur
le terrain est toujours complexe donc
mais malgré tout un avis défavorable
merci monsieur chevrollier monsieur le
ministre
défavorable
si madame sollogoub oui je vous remercie
en fait dans un monde parfait cet
amendement devrait être satisfait je
vais je vais le maintenir pour le
principe parce que monsieur le ministre
vous êtes devant nous au vu du nombre de
questions qui sont posées régulièrement
par tous les collègues que ce soit de
l'assemblée ou du sénat par écrit ou par
oral
le problème n'est pas réglé et la fibre
n'est pas encore arrivé partout il ya
des personnes qui se retrouvent dans une
situation d'attenté peut pas leur dire
d'attendre pendant des années la fibre
et voilà mais je profite de cet
amendement pour vous demander de nous
aider parce que on ne peut pas laisser
des gens sans un accès filet au cuivre
c'est un service de base qu'on ne
fournit pas à tout le monde sur le
territoire c'est pas acceptable en
france actuellement
si chers collègues je mets aux voix
l'amendement 27 rectifié qui a reçu un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
[Musique]
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je
mets aux voix l'article 15 qui est pour
et contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
[Musique]